good
evening everybody and welcome to the
constitutional review working party
um any members of the public present no
so we can ignore saying welcome to them
fire evacuation procedure if the firearm
is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs either
through the security door
or opposite the lifts in the foyer
please do not use the lift
assembling all the square on the green
and officers will assist you and advise
when it's deemed safe to return
does anyone intend to film the meeting
any member of the public objects
would everyone please ensure their
mobile phones are turned to silent and
they are not used to make or receive
calls in the chamber whilst the meeting
is broadcast
please notice that this meeting is being
live streamed for members of the public
and except for items of business or
exempt or confidence left
information is considered following the
exclusion of the press and public from
the meeting
this meeting is also being recorded and
will be broadcast on the internet
does any member wish to speak under
council procedural 20.1 please announce
it now
are there any apologies for absence
minutes of the meeting held on the 23rd
of february i moved that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 23rd of february
be approved
and signed as a correct record could i
have a second please
thank you council heart unless any
objections to the minutes i'll take them
as agreed
thank you are there any decorations of
interest
item agenda for draft member parental
leave policy
mr hughes will now present the report
thank you chairman um so i'll briefly
outline the report so um
this is a proposed um parental leave
policy for
councillors um it
whilst there is no legal list of
requirement for us to do
such a policy um it would be quite a
progressive thing for the council to do
and one of the main aims is to reduce
barriers to
uh entry as councillors effectively
um and uh one of the things that we did
find the last election
of in the run-up to the last election
was um people were
very interested in in
removing those barriers and uh
more so allowing a better family life
balance between
um their private lives and um
their council lives um so
whilst we are not legally required to
have a policy uh as i said it would be
quite progressive things
to do um and and outlined at 1.5 in the
report as a couple of statistics
from the fawcett society so just four
percent of local councils in england
currently have a formal parental leave
policy
um and it also found that
a third of female councillors of
childbearing age found that a lack of
paternity
leave to be a barrier to fulfilling
their role
what we have done is is create a number
of options
for members to have a look through to
see whether any of them feel as if they
are appropriate to be
recommended on to the standards
committee
one of the things that i should make
clear about the
report and the annexes is the annexes do
refer
to the um
split or the changes into allowances
they are only the changes to allow to
these special responsibility allowances
a member will always get their basic
allowance because
just because you're pregnant or have a
paternity leave doesn't mean say you
wouldn't be a counselor you will stay
being a counsellor and all the time you
stay being a counsellor you're entitled
to your basic allowance
so that will not change the the
policy will only apply to special
responsibility allowances
to just make that really clear
so what we will do
is
allow as part of this policy to have a
blanket covering
of uh an exemption from the uh
sections of local government 72 act that
requires you to have been a councillor
or had to attend a meeting for at least
a six-month period
um so i'm not sure councillors have
aware that you have to attend at least
one council meeting
um within a six-month period otherwise
you would be um
removed as councillor so by adopting
this policy what we're suggesting is
that
a member wouldn't have to come to
council to say well
i'm i'm pregnant or i want some
fraternity leave
please can i have an exemption from that
six-month rule because that's
not particularly effective use of
council's time and really shouldn't
really be
um subject to a vote
after full council meeting so by having
this policy um this is a
effectively a blanket uh exemption from
that
um well exemption's probably not the
right word it's not really a
exemption from the law it's an automatic
acceptance that that is a valid reason
for
not coming to a meeting within six
months probably a better way of
describing it
so that is uh the main element of it
with regards to the actual sort of
financial elements of it uh that's sort
of outlined
at um paragraph it's paragraph four
isn't it i think
through yeah paragraph four of the annex
of the actual
report so there are three options um
so you have option one which is 10 weeks
of
sra at 90 of what
the earnings are per week followed by
16 weeks at 50 percent um
and then unpaid leave thereafter up to
52 weeks
this is a very similar approach to
um the the scheme that
mem officers have
not to say that it is
based on that but it's effectively it's
a mirror image of it
um the second option which is in line
with the current policy for mps
is that you have six months full pay of
their
stretch of the special responsibility
allowance
and then the rest of the time that
they're off up to 52 weeks is
unpaid or then the third option which is
in line with the um draft model that the
local government association created is
that the member
who is on potential maternity leave
receives full pay
of their members allowance of their
special responsibility allowance
um throughout the whole of that period
so obviously that's uh slightly more
generous so you've got three levels of
um generosity i think probably not the
best way of describing it but
um three different options with various
outlays there for members to have a look
at
um yeah that's pretty much
it really unless there's anything else
that still wants to add to that or
no okay so through youtube i'll open it
up to questions
anybody wish to make any comment
counselor ashby
thank you chair um thank you for
explaining regarding the attendance
with the uh if you like the
constitutional
requirements to attend one meeting
there's no
there's nowhere in it though that
specifically mentions the override
i appreciate that you're saying that it
does override
the um but i can't actually find where
there's a
specific mention to it overriding the
requirement for members
to attend at least one meeting within a
six month period
might have missed that but um the other
the other point is
is um well the other question is um
have other authorities local authorities
adopted this
and and if or are we the pioneers of it
which would be rather nice
but if we're not um what other
authorities which
which options of other authorities
chosen
thank you so um it's the
paragraph at 1.8 at the um
annex which effectively um
has that statement in it that says um
because
the council will have agreed this policy
it therefore allows anybody who is then
um taking leave as a result of maternity
or paternity
or shared parental adoption leave
effectively means that the council has
granted
anybody who then says that they are
pregnant
a exemption from that or an extension i
think is probably a better word to use
in the extent an exemption isn't it
probably
um an extension to their that six month
period until such point as they come
back
or whether their leave finishes is that
does that
make sense okay um and um
yeah i would agree with you i would
agree with you this we are certainly at
the
um i wouldn't say forefront but we're
certainly near the front of the train
rather than at the end of the train
with regards to um where we are in in
relation to other councils in
introducing such a policy i know that uh
i think there's a couple
um sunderland newcastle and birmingham
have all got
policies um and i think there's one
other council
which i think don't quote me is i think
it might be it's either tunbridge or
temperature
[ __ ] never much [ __ ] turn
bridge wells or temperature mauling
i think are one of the the only other
people in kent who've got a policy like
this
um so we are quite near the um
quite near the forefront which is quite
a good thing to be um
it's quite unusual for for us to be
quite so
um trailblazing
i think
anybody council heart
thank you chair um unless i've misread
this or i'll just be
i just skip past it um does this include
children being adopted
and um my other concern
is that if it is done for councillors
one assumes that from the date that you
incept it to the
to the end of that six months let's say
they cannot vote on anything
thank you so
firstly firstly yes it does apply to
adoption
so it's fully covered adoption leave as
well
and with regards to um voting yes you're
right effectively it is
leave it is it's effectively they won't
be here for
however long their parental leave lasts
um and then um they asked
they are effectively keep that role in
abeyance effectively it's
they they are still that cabinet member
for example because to be honest it's
mostly going to be
cabinet members or chairs of committees
um so what would happen
is that we would elect another person to
be that
effectively take on that role for the
period that
the person is off on paternity leave and
they would also be entitled to the same
allowance
that the person sorry stupid mask
the same allowance that the person who's
on leave is getting
now yes that is more money but
there is enough money within the
allowances budget to take that
and whilst um
there is and it's perfectly reasonable
to be concerned about the finances
um i think it's unlikely that there
would be such an influx of people
wishing to take maternity opportunity
that it would
adversely impact the budget that we have
available
council hopkinson
[Music]
thank you chair um well i'd just like to
commend the uh
the proposal in general um in particular
because there's um
there's a problem nationally with um
attracting and
retaining people in their 20s 30s and
40s
to bay councils and local authorities so
i think this is a really
uh good step in terms of that um can i
just ask for
clarification um because if i understood
right you said that
none of this wouldn't affect uh this
would only affect
special responsibility analysis but it
wouldn't affect members announcers at
all
um but if but i'm just looking at uh
paragraph 4.1
because option my understanding of
option one is that it suggests that
there is
with option one there would be a
reduction
in members allowances during this period
because that's
um so i'm not sure if did you mean that
don't worry
i just wanted to understand that
basically
yes that was what i was referring to at
the start which is that option one
and option two refer to it being related
to members allowances when they
shouldn't it should only be
relating to special responsibility
allowances you're right as i say
um the basic 4500 and
something or other pound the basic
allowance everybody gets that
irrespective and you're not allowed to
you're not allowed to
suspend elements of that at all that's
that's not on you can't do that again
um so um and just because somebody's on
parental leave doesn't stop them being a
counselor they are a counselor from the
moment they're elected to the time their
four-year period finishes
so um they would get their basic
allowance
yeah because we couldn't because yeah if
you think about it if we
if we did it as per this you'd actually
see a cut in you'd actually be worse off
than
than not telling us that you were
pregnant which is just yeah that
wouldn't work so
um yeah so ignore the bit where it says
members allowances it's
just special responsibility answers
anybody else got any comments to make mr
welbeck
yeah just uh i don't know a great deal
about the
the the details of counsellor's
remuneration
uh but just as a general principle
uh from an outsider point of view i
i would have thought mimicking as much
as possible
the employees arrangements for uh
parental leave
will be seen to be a good principal to
adopt rather than having something
that is potentially worse or better
or better off than the employees so
there's a degree of i think of equality
amongst
both members and and officers
okay thank you councillorski
yeah i think uh looking at it i would
agree um
the last speaker that we shouldn't
be looking to get better than what the
employees get
looking at this 4.1
it mirrors the provision of for staff
um even though they don't get statutory
maternity pay it's not
uh that's not i don't think an issue i
don't think that's an issue
um if they were in another employment
they will get their maternity pay from
that in any case so
that's not an issue i i'd be inclined to
vote for 4.1 so
thank you
has anybody else got any comments they
wish to make
in that case can we first of all deal
with option one
do members wish to make any
recommendations to the standard
committee in relation to
option one can i have a proposal please
yeah i'd like to propose option one
sorry do members agree
i think we might have to take a vote on
that then right
yeah council hopkinson thank you
sorry i think this is maybe a
misunderstood here
because i thought we were saying option
one is not adequate it's not
accurately word is at the moment
so because that's the one that's saying
that there's a uh
a reduction to 90 of the members
allowance
for the first 10 weeks and then 50 in in
[Music]
the later period whereas
so yeah so if i could suggest a slight
tweak to the proposal to say that
we we recommend to standard option one
subject to
the allow the members allow where the
reference to members allowances
being deleted because that i think would
then
resolve it in the sense that we were
saying that
you'd get you your basic allowance will
just carry on
that will just happen and then if you
are entitled to then having a special
responsibility allowance
you would get 90 of your special
responsibility allowance
for 10 weeks after that you'd then get
50 of your special responsibilities
allowance for another 16 weeks
and then you get unpaid you'd stop
getting your special responsibility
for allowance for that for the rest of
the time that you are then
on parental leave up until a maximum of
52 weeks
is that does that make sense
cool okay yeah i'll admit my proposal to
include that
but can i kind of just say looking at
the wording for that
and you may wish to members want to
amend it further
where it says 16 weeks at 50 of normal
earnings
would it not be better worded 50 of
sra were applicable because you then
you've already asked for members
allowances to be removed
from the first bit reading the second
bit is contradicting
the first bit if you follow me
yeah that's a great child i'm happy for
that to be uh part of the proposal
counselor heart thank you jess we're
nitpicking
um i just wonder if there should be a
certain time you've been in that role
before that becomes applicable
so you know you're not given that role
and then a day later you just said
oh by the way i'm pregnant um and and so
therefore
you have some sort of stabilizing effect
on the council as well as um in your
group
that was all
i'm not sure you can do that legally
i think i might ask mr used to answer
that one yeah
i might back that away to a sterling
section
um sorry was your question that somebody
might be a bit
a bit devious and take the special
responsibility allowance and then the
day later say
oh by the way i'm pregnant uh sorry
i'm sorry direct into the wrong moment
it's been a long day
um i'm not sure there's any way you
could
counter against that really i think that
might just be the
the way the cookie crumbles in reality
it's unlikely to happen
in reality this policy
is unlikely to apply to that many people
and i should imagine if it
if it does apply to anybody it would
well i don't know that might happen but
i think it's i think it's fairly
unlikely
and i don't really think you could put
anything in place to
to mitigate against it so
so correct me sorry
yeah i think i mean in employment law
that
you would be in all sorts of bother if
you uh
if you started to try and word it around
that because it's
um obviously um uh and it's not all
also for ladies becoming pregnant also
this has got a paternity
issue um and um
happened to know that uh my cabinet is
uh expecting
he is expecting their first child so um
he might be the first to uh recognize
this but uh
um yeah i mean i i don't think that we
need to be that prescriptive i
would just like to um if we could recap
on the actual
wording of what we're agreeing here
thank
can you from what we've all just said
that option one
4.1 i think what council is actually
saying is
10 weeks at 90 of average weekly
earnings
and special allowance were applicable
followed by 16 weeks 50 sra
followed by unpaid leave for any
additional leave agreed up to 52 weeks
and this is a this is a payment on a
sizing scale for six months
is that what you're saying
yeah that's correct counsel ashby
oh um i don't actually like the word
earnings because we we don't have
earnings
we are not paye we do not get um
benefits for being payed so and
um i think to the general public um it's
it's the wrong word to use we have an
allowance so
10 weeks at 90 of average
allowance uh not members allowance but
we we should say sra allowance i mean
it's actually quite important that word
earnings i don't think should be in
there because we don't
earn this is not an earning this is
purely a member's allowance so and it
would be totally misconceived by
the general public to think that we are
i mean i appreciate this has probably
been taken from
a sort of standard employment type
contracty thing but
members don't come under that type of
contract so
um i don't know quite how we're gonna
get around the wording but i
i think yeah counselor at hopkins
thank you um so i know it's been
suggested that option one is preferable
but i'm just wondering what is the
rationale for wanting to reduce the um
allowance first to 90 and 50 um
because without understanding that it
seems to me option three is preferable
so i just wonder if if there are if
members have a rationale for why
they would want that to be reduced
council russitsky yeah i think the
rationale was
was the fact that it is in line with
what the staff get
uh rather than being someone special or
anything like
that it was that the fact this is what
the council staff get we shouldn't be
any different
from them when uh when when we discuss
our allowances
etc
council robinson okay
i understand yeah but i wonder if um
i mean i mean
it just seems to me that it's we should
be deciding in terms of
what's fair in terms of this policy and
if um
if we're not saying that what
i mean there's a kind of a race to the
bottom uh idea isn't it if um
unless we're actually saying what we
think happens to staff is is
particularly
fair and in line with what we think
should happen then uh
i don't know couldn't we just go by what
we what we do think is fair for
members and given that we're not setting
pay for
for staff then i just wonder how
relevant that is
yes sister
um thank you chair if i if you if i may
i i have a view about this if you don't
mind and i'm sorry nick if it cuts
across your view
um i i'm not sure we could actually
we should actually compare this to
members of staff because members of
staff have all sorts of other benefits
through their employment
including a um you know very good
maternity and paternity leave package
including pay
um and i wonder whether you know all the
options are perfectly valid
but uh when i looked at this i actually
thought that option two
sounded quite a good a good compromise
which is very straightforward which is
basically
the pay that sits within the six months
standard leave period and then any
further leave period after that would be
by agreement
but actually there's nothing wrong with
option three as well because
the reality is there will be a cost to
the council of this
but it's not likely to be a massive cost
and actually put together the basic
allowance and the special responsibility
allowance is probably not that much
relatively speaking um certainly for the
amount that
the councillors do particularly if you
have a special responsibility allowance
and special responsibility
um so i mean my view is that well any of
the options are perfectly valid but
actually
i thought personally and i know it's not
my decision
that either option two or option three
would be um preferable
and i'm sorry nick if that upsets you
cash
yeah i mean i didn't take the point it
was it was a good point
from council exactly but i just want i'm
a little bit concerned that it might
undercut the point of the
the whole proposal because reducing um
the so i'm just going to get my screen
back up so i can see it
um reducing it to 50 that might be of
concern to
someone that's in that position to the
point where it poses them a financial
problem which is
obviously what we're trying to avoid
so and also particularly given the fact
that as as has been said it's unlikely
that many people are going to be using
this
um it might be possible to
you know avoid undermining the purpose
of the whole thing
with option two or three
okay i think the sensible way to do it
is we've got a proposal for option one
i don't intend to take a voters yet as
anybody wish to speak only
option two and we'll do the same process
there if that
is a proposal and second and the same
again with option three
counselor ashby thank you chair
um just for um clarity
so auction one is 4.1 option 2 is 4.1
and option 3 is 4.2
i'm a bit confused should that be
4.14.24.3
just so that we are clear and i
having listened to um estelle
um i would be inclined because i don't
i feel quite strongly about that we are
not
paye and we are not paid
um as such you know it's not an earnings
it's a
totally different sort of set up um and
having listened to estelle
i would be inclined to because of this
issue that
i feel that that could lead to then i
think
option two which i believe should
probably be 4.2
um would be the easiest way and the
fairest way
um uh as iselle quite rightly puts it
members and we're on a totally different
um setup from start staff on poa they
get sick pay holiday pay all sorts of
and obviously they have their paternity
and maternity package
so i think councillor hodgson's is quite
right
is that we we don't need to be kept
comparing
like for like because it's it's not like
polite so
i think in this option too would satisfy
i think everything
from that point of view so thank you
chair
okay in that case i don't know if you're
happy with the suggestion i made
is there a proposal for option two
councillor ashby is a seconder
secondary councillor hopkinson
is there a proposal for option three
no okay in that case i think we should
take a
unless anybody's got anything else to do
to say take a vote on option
one all those in favor of option one
two those against
through esther
you do vote to say vote for option
one or option two
i'm guided by what mr hughes has said
right so the voting
to start with all those in favor of
option two
well you can do it either way it doesn't
matter
the vote is not the vote isn't vote for
what
sorry recommendation yeah it's not vote
for one or don't vote for one it's
vote for option one or vote for option
two right okay
that's the way you want to do it right
okay right so
those who want to recommend option one
to start with
and those who want to recommend option
two
so that is carried then so it'd be
option two
that six months full pay of
allowances special responsibility
allowance were applicable
with any remaining leave being unpaid
that is a recommendation to go to the
standards committee
everybody's nodding great do we
do we need to leave the word members
allowance out
on option two
fine
so clarity um is it 4.2
is there a typo on the on the 4.1 4.2.3
yes but i didn't write it but i didn't i
didn't write this
i just said
we'll renumber it for standards but yeah
you